all of this covid misinformation is
coming on the heels
of
several governors who are banning
measures
to mitigate the spread of infection
hospitalization
and death
abbott in texas desantis in florida
all these areas across the country that
are led by ridiculous charlatan clowns
in the governor's offices
and it is good news to hear that several
local organizational efforts are being
made in in municipalities across those
states
to counteract to defy the order
of banning mass mandates reading from
the hill florida school board votes to
keep mass mandate defying desantis the
broward county school board on tuesday
voted eight to one
to retain its mass mandate for students
and staff members defying florida
governor ron desantis's executive order
forcing school districts to make masks
optional
the fort lauderdale school board is
seeking legal counsel to challenge the
executive order which it claims
represents government overreach
according to wplg
quote wearing masks inside schools
regardless of vaccine status is required
to deal with the changing realities of
virus transmission
it is a necessary precaution until
children under 12 can receive a covet 19
vaccination and more americans 12 and
older get vaccinated which came from
anifusco president of the broward
teachers union it's not just florida
though in texas again there are measures
in place to defy the governor's
anti-health
mandates
this is ksat the san antonio affiliate
judge delivers blow to texas governor
abbott's
ban on mandates allows san antonio to
require mass in schools temporary
restraining order allows san antonio
bexar county
to impose mass mandates
san antonio leaders scored a victory in
court against texas governor greg abbott
on tuesday in the ongoing fight over
mass mandates a beckster county civil
district court judge granted the city of
bexar county's request
for temporary restraining order against
abbott's executive order banning mass
mandates in school
again other than
uh fueling the culture war
what
is the the impetus here
what is the goal what is the objective
in banning in in creating a system where
local municipalities listen republicans
always say this
local authorities know better than the
federal government they know what's best
for them
well why is that not the case for a
local city
to impose a mass mandate for their
community
their local community
who is
is greg abbott the governor of texas who
is he to know more about what's best for
that local community
using republican logic
than the community itself
instead
they are prohibiting local
municipalities to create more stringent
rules surrounding protecting the health
and welfare of their residents
effectively the ruling allows bexar
county and san antonio officials to
issue a mass mandate in public schools
and other guidance like quarantine
protocol for now
officials say they plan to have an order
issued by the end of tuesday no details
have been released yet on the guidance
but officials will hold a live press
conference at 6 10 pm
the order was granted after an hour-long
hearing at by the 57th civil district
court with judge tony or tiaga ortiaga
said an affidavit from metro health
chief medical officer dr jundo wu
weighed heavily in her decision as did
the vulnerability of children who were
returning to school amid a surge in
coronavirus cases
that sentence bears repeating weighed on
her heavily on her decision was the
vulnerability of children who are
returning to school amid a surge in
coronavirus cases
and this is what is perplexing it is
baffling to me because although
republican they're still human beings
ostensibly they possess
some level of empathy unless they they
suffer from sociopathy
why don't they care about the surging
cases of coronavirus
all across
their states
this is from louisiana reading from the
insider a new orleans children's
hospital doctor says reopening schools
without masks
is a formula for disaster as covid19
rages in louisiana
this isn't just salacious use of words
in these headlines
the pandemic is raging
a year and a half in it is raging in
these areas louisiana has finally seen
an uptick in vaccinations in the
vaccination rates of its citizens
because of the fact that people look
around and they know
they have family members who are dogging
they have family members maybe multiple
who are hospitalized they're witnessing
children now
get sick
reopening schools loaded with
unvaccinated children and no mask
requirements in place is a formula for
disaster the physician and chief of the
children's hospital new orleans said
i think bringing together large numbers
of children congregating them in
classrooms with masks being optional or
worse yet even forbidden
is just a formula for disaster dr mark
klein said
in an interview with cnn
it couldn't be more plainly stated
republicans have turned the culture war
uh the war on christmas and what color
coffee cup starbucks has these nonsense
arguments they have turned it into
something that is deadly
it's one thing if you want to whine
about the the national anthem and
someone silently kneeling in protest and
you want to turn that into a culture war
it's another thing entirely when you
endanger the lives of children
innocent babies
who are
have no other choice but to be protected
they cannot do it themselves
we're not horses or goats or cows
they get squirted out and immediately
are on our feet walking around eating
grass that's not how it works with human
beings
i'm sad to say republicans
we need nurturing
and protection
for a great deal of time before we're
capable of doing it ourselves
and greg abbott and ron desantis are
getting in the way of that
they're making a choice
to force
municipalities into a situation where
they're either violating the law
or making sure their kids are safe
unconscionable